I was wondering you know that famous was
a cup with him Wilhelm scream yeah yeah
the guy he throws off when he like jumps
up here let's play that moment not not
with devil m11 it as an Evan screw it
all that we're all just waiting to get
to the chorus on that song yeah oh you
know cuz it's the most eccentric part
guys I'm Greg I I am John apparently
there's a better venom clip out there
another better venom cliff yeah you
don't say this is a Sony picture I like
the title of it to protect and sever ooh
it's like it's an anagram with one
letter change yeah I don't know it's
really in this clip but guys I wanted to
let you know that if you want our very
first thoughts right while we're walking
out of the movie go follow us on the
Stardust app people link in the
description box 30-second reaction so
DPhil TV show or trailer oh man we have
so much fun posting over there sometimes
we might even do a wacky 30-second
sketch the app is free this shout out
that we're doing is free no one's paying
us we just like using it knock knock
what the devil in let's watch this 37
seconds of what I can assume is
awesomeness seven extra seconds
you do not want to do this trust me oh
wow there's great hey
the welcome screen getting low-keyed
right now ah I wanted more of that
that's the most thrilling John you got
feel both oh damn not really hard Eddie
Brock hard solid right now whoa that
clip was surprisingly well worth it
actually yeah nice to see something new
something with a bit of style and
suspense some edge to the big upset has
been at this film is pg-13 but you can
have a hard pg-13 is there footage of
Joker pencil moment or like any of that
middle east stuff from the Robocop real
just without blood what he's fighting
those cops I'm pretty he's malevolent as
he's ever been in this one the scene
here I was just really hoping that every
time you if you don't play the song you
just hear
[Music]
hey it's safe to say that none of those
guys knew what hit him you know they
might as well it was so cool cuz we
needs it what he's like you see that one
cop yeah just when I we made one video
where I was where I said you know I was
rewashing the trailers and I actually
I'm losing faith that this will actually
be good at most I said in there that I
feel like I'm most it'll be entertaining
ly cheesy but that was legit cool I want
to watch that one more time
he seems like penguin from Gotham
dude the action is direct it's so good
yes looks really cool I'll have to
follow up like it gives it kind of a
[ __ ] menace to that a guy is dead
yeah that guy's got a broken spine like
this gets me the most excited probably
that I've been cuz yeah like you know we
talked about that last trailer being
like I don't know and then everyone the
comments was like whatever man to see
just like an uninterrupted scene yeah
even for 30 seconds looks pretty fun
masks coffee that ya know his
personality I don't know maybe it's the
poi nose at the pointy ears but a lot of
it is all mannerisms in this specific
moment I don't feel like through all of
this movie I'll be thinking a penguin
from the Gotham show I feel like in this
specific boat but I'm really reminded of
the actor who plays penguin ear which
isn't a bad thing I love that actor in
that show I'm just hoping Tom Hardy's
this sweaty of the whole movie because
it's something that struck me about so
much what it does he's like really
sweaty especially like once venom takes
it I guess you would be yeah you got
parasite this at least solidifies faith
to me I don't know how the in-between
the action stuff is gonna be but if this
thirty Seconds is a resemblance of the
kind of action to expect to still get
some like whoa that's brutal without the
blood and gore at him and like literally
biting at humans head off and stuff
that's kind of a bummer to hear is not
in the movie if the action is this like
brutal I feel like it'll be the major
saving grace of the film because I was
like alright cool yeah I'm at least
gonna be thoroughly entertained but I'm
watching his film you know pleasure
really stepping up I mean it seems like
he's kind of pulling from all of his
different movies to make this because
you know it's got some of the horror
vibes that zombieland kind of had but
it's also got the action vibes that you
know gangster squad
yeah kind of brought into the equation
and I'm sure there will be some humor
cuz it's a Marvel adjacent movies they
want this in Marvel so yeah
yeah and also I mean just you know the
visuals the the stuff we're like you
know they got the bombs going off and
you see the the symbiotes yeah like kind
of freaking out like I love those little
moments and stuff and Venom looks like
truly monstrous in this trailer
Otis please tell you've heard that song
I want I just want there to be a day
where we all take five minutes to all
collectively as world walk outside and
just sing that yeah you could hear
across the world already coming together
for I was wondering you know that famous
it was a co Wilhelm scream yeah yeah the
guy he throws off when he like jumps up
here let's play that moment I think it
might be yeah I feel like cuz that's the
thing that editors love the cheesy ass
laughs yeah like a real scream of a guy
falling for ya maybe in the r-rated cut
he screams much lower more terrified Lee
but I mean it's better than that Tom
Cruise mummy scream
but I've never been in a plane crash so
maybe that's just how you say screaming
a plane crash but do you know who's not
a screamer is a cage for the day shout
out for Adelia chamberlain chain bow I
was talking with Adelia recently and
Adelia I agree with you man she's have
said about how people are really
complaining about Captain Marvel not
really smiling or showing charm and the
trailers and everyone's talking about
like oh she's gonna be a bland boring
character and you know I want to make
something clear that's it you guys can
subscribe I want to make something clear
even though I've made my jokes about
that in like the first look photos and
even in the trailer I agree with the
delia that hey I don't know probably at
B I'm sure she's gonna have a charming
personality it's brie Larson she's a
great actress and I do think too that if
and I I'm not just saying this to like
sound like I'm fighting the right fight
it's I just agree with it if it was a
man it wouldn't have been much of a
complaint fair and square Ryan Gosling
does it in 9 out of every 10 movies he's
quiet and stoic and everything there's
nothing yet to really suggest that
that's how the whole movie gonna be it's
just you know a bunch of photographs and
then you know the trailer doesn't
showcase a lot of her personality but
you know I haven't seen the movie so
Adelia I want you to know that I'm right
there by your side women are allowed to
be more serious in movie trailers and
movies as well
Captain America doesn't really smile
Captain America thing is I fully agree
with them like I don't want her to smile
only I'm not just like oh I just like
I've heard so much about this character
I would like to get a sense for she's a
more serious character so I want to use
this shout-out to tell you Adelia I'm on
your side I'm on your side guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
notification bells and hey why don't you
go ahead check us out on the Stardust
app TV shows you know we already
scrapped at the beginning
link in description box bye